الذهب له اهميه خاصه عند الاسره المصريه
فهو الهديه القيمه شبكه العروس ولا ادخار
الامن للمستقبل
هو جميل مجوهرات جميله وطبعا ادخار يعني
قبل اي شيء
بعد كده يطلعه غويشه
دي ثقافه المصريين
بمشاركه عدد كبير من صناع وتجار الذهب
مجوهرات
خاصه في العشر سنوات الاخيره صارت منافسه
عالميه جدا بالنسبه للمنتجاتها لاذواق
لاوزانه وامتلئ السوق العالمي
والارتباك شهدتها اسواق الذهب في الفتره
الاخيره حيث ارتفع سعر جرام الذهب الارقام
غير مسبوقه نتيجه للتضخم المحليه
ما اثر على حركه البيع والشراء
ارتفاع سعر العمله والتضخم جعل من الذهب
القيمه المضمونه وليس فقط للزينه
شايفه ان هو مخزن جيد للقيمه يعني على
اساس ان هو ارتفاع الاسعار هتبقى الجنيه
لما ينخفض يبقى هو محتفظ بنفسه بالفلوس
اللي هي البناتي كده اشتري يعني البسها
بعدين والشراء لا مش باشتري اسعار الذهب
لا دي حاجه مش مش منطقيه خالص ودي رافعه
مش عاديه الاول
السبب بسعر عالمي السعر عالمي مش مضبوط
طبعا احنا مش عارفين نشتغل بسعر
الدولار طبعا مش مستقر في البلد يعني مش
عارفين اسعار ماشيه ازاي هو ده هو الفتره
دي طبعا
وبعدما كان الذهب من عيار 18 21 هو السائد
في السوق
ظهر عيار 14 واصبح له زبائنه لانخفاض سعره
اقل من عيار 18 هو عيار 14 في 60 في الميه
من الذهب و 40% من الاضافات الثقافه في
مصر بقت متعوده على عيار 14 بدات سالت
عليها في المحلات القطاعي
في الايام الاخيره قد الغت الرسوم على
الصادرات الذهب والمقدره بنصف في المئه
لتشجيع التصدير المشغولات الذهبيه مشهوره
عند المصريين منذ العهد الفرعوني وما زالت
تشكل جزءا مهما من عادات الحياه اليوميه
ومنها الزواج ما ادى الى تعالي الاصوات
المطالبه للاسر بعدم المغالاه في تحديد
قيمه الشبكه للتسير على الشباب
[موسيقى]
هيروح يجيب ذهب ولا هيفرق الشقه ولا خصوصه
في ظل ارتفاع الاسعار اللي حصل
على راسي قائمه اهتمامات المصريين سمر
باشات للصباح العربيه من القاهره
[موسيقى]